this is my honest reaction to the new DC
slate and James Gunn's announcement
yesterday I haven't looked at the Slate
yet I am going to literally look at it
first time while I'm on video with you
this video will not be massively edited
if at all and well you know I just want
to give you my honest reaction to this
so welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a
movie channel
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
polygon just this is the first one I
found it was actually like listed rather
than
um a big long story and then you have to
figure it out so anyway the new dce
movies like this is the one that's I'm
probably the most interesting for most
people is the Superman Legacy project so
this is going to be looking at
before amount of Steel now this is my
first I'm here you can say that
with the DC and James Gunn they seem to
be doing a bit of um
a hybrid hard reboot now I have seen the
interview a little bit where James Gunn
is talking about how the DC has been a
bit of a mess over the last 15 years or
so it's been all over the bloody place
with our reverse and everything else um
and I know that the new Batman the um
Patterson version of Batman is going to
be sort of the DC extra thing and so is
um sort of like the Superman on
um the CW so
um Superman and Lois
um so they they seem to be trying to
organize the DC now into very much the
DC the DC Universe and anything that's
sort of outside of that like the Joker
the John Phoenix thing
um will be separate but it'll be very
much distinctly tagged as separate so I
kind of understand that and they're
trying to I think that is important
though because we've got it's got to
bring us into the universe isn't it
you've got to kind of almost feel like
it's real it's got to be organized or
you kind of lose some of the reality to
but anyway so yeah no Henry Cavill
um
Legacy will follow Carlisle as he
reconciles his extraterologians with his
human family and upbringing so he's
going to be a young Superman so hey
let's see that I mean over 10 15 years
it might be actually quite interesting
to see how Superman does reconcilize I
think but we kind of got to see that in
Smallville
that was the kind of pointless movie so
it's going to be basically Smallville
light as far as I'm concerned or
Smallville the movie
uh The Authority or the authority is
quite cool I do know this comic book
um so yeah this is a bit like Marvel if
you can there's a lot of equivalence
between DC and Marvel and this is a bit
like that movie Marvel did last year
which is rubbish
and anyway um I can't remember what it's
called it's so bad it's just shut my
mind and left my brain
um Jack Hawks more you know is
physically bonded to cities that was a
strange storyline so yeah this superhero
is actually like gets his power from
cities
um
anyway
oh it's it's an interesting storyline I
do remember the comics vaguely
um that that must tie into a bigger
storyline though
um I do vaguely think that James Gunn
has talked about there being a big
overarcher storyline for this first
phase
um monsters and heroes or some whatever
it's called
um so okay
right the Brave and the Bold
silver HDC Comics uh is this the one
with Robin is um actually Batman's son
it is so right okay so Batman is going
to be um Batman's actually so Robin is
actually Batman's son and if I remember
correctly from the comics it's a
troubled relationship day and Robin was
brought up by somebody else he didn't
know he was
um Batman's son until he's like 10 or 11
or something and then he becomes he's
like an assassin
he's a troubled kid anyway
um and then Batman and his whole story
about that troubled relationship so this
is going to be the Batman family that
we've heard so much about
um and we're going to see Batgirl and
stuff again I imagine so all right this
is really
um it's quite a a middle-aged sort of
Batman and a young Robin so look my
first instinct on that is it hasn't
worked before
um it's gonna have to require a
different take on Batman look any story
can be done well I always think like um
Ant-Man Ant-Man from the Marvel series I
when that came out I thought this is
going to be stupid it's Ant-Man it's a
stupid name it's a stupid superhero it's
not going to make a very good film but
Marvel did a good job with it because
they sort of took on board and they had
a little bit of tongue and cheek where
it was necessary but then they took it
seriously enough so the robin character
kind of really needs that a little bit
it needs to be taken seriously but also
needs a little bit of tongue and cheek
so let's see Supergirl oh
to Supergirl
um based on Tom King's comic book series
okay that was um uh Supergirl was
um brought apart she wasn't brought up
on Earth was she
and
yeah she she's a slightly more troubled
character if I remember right so let's
see Faye Dunaway is a nemesis okay uh
Helen Slater is going to be starring and
it's a thing okay
hey let's say sort of thing
you've got to be kidding me they can't
do a swamp thing that's a movie as well
that's not a TV series they're doing a
movie of The Swamp Thing
right it looks like they're gonna go
dark without them so that's gonna be
like a horror movie
oh yes where's Craven did the first one
so
that that's that's a that's a comic book
that really is limited they're trying to
do this in a TV series not long ago
actually I think it was on the CW I'm
not sure but it was rubbish
um
every time they've tried to do that it's
been rubbish so again they're gonna have
to do that very very cleverly
um
dce DCU TV shows uh create Creature
Commandos I think that's the cartoon
isn't it I think it's going to be a
cartoon
um in it Amanda Waller forms a super
team with monstrous prisoner so it's
another take on suicide squad
um and then they are doing a wall of TV
series as well so I've put that to live
action I believe so I believe Creature
Commandos is going to be a cartoon and
that's what I was told by sources a
couple of weeks ago that the one at
least one of these big projects would be
a cartoon it would be this Creature
Commandos thing I think
um James Gunn's writing that himself if
I remember right
um Walla um oh yeah this is the one
thing that apparently The Peacemaker
season two is being delayed
um Waller's gonna be done first and some
Of The Peacemaker characters will be in
it hopefully Peacemaker himself because
that would be awesome
um and yeah
um that would be that would be very cool
I'd be okay with with that wallet TV
series I think the actress that plays
wallet is is just a phenomenal actress
so if they do that right
and again I assume that's going to be
something that's going to be tagged in
with whatever the big story arc is
um
so Booster Gold right now this Booster
Gold is a character that's appeared in
DC a few times now he's actually
appeared in the TV series once or twice
I can't remember if it was Arrow or uh
the flash they appeared in briefly one
of the early seasons of that and and so
he's from the future and he's a bit of a
loser but he uses future technology and
then he's come back into the past to
become a superhero but he's a complete
idiot so I'm assuming that's going to be
a slightly tongue-in-cheek a bit like
Peacemaker
um a lot more humor involved in that
Series so let's see how that works that
could be good look I hated Suicide Squad
the second one in particular but then
Peacemaker came off that and I loved
Peacemaker it just tickled my stupid
bone in my brain you know
um and I shouldn't have liked it because
it's inane Stupid humor but I just
adored it
um lanterns okay a TV series of lanterns
so that's going to be based on an
offense
um it's Hal Jordan and and John Stewart
okay great
um to the big things so that that'll be
Precinct Terror I think it's called um
so the Earth space Precinct
um
uh unraveling a dark mystery right now I
could this was going to be like a buddy
cop show basically so if that's if
that's still the plan and then that's
interesting and then I imagine again
that will bleed into whatever this big
story over an arc in story is then you
know the Thanos of this of this story if
you like and Paradise Lost us is that
the Wonder Woman show yeah so that's a
Wonder Woman show and that's I imagine
now he has said James Gunn has said that
Gal Gadot can still appear in Wonder
Woman as Wonder Woman but this is a
reboot it feels like because this is
back on her
um the island where she grew up and
everything
um oh this calls it a Game of Thrones
Style Show
the Genesis the drama focuses on the
Genesis and political Intrigue of an
island of all women
I'm not making any I'm not touching that
with a barge problem I'm making no jokes
about that
um but very Game of Thrones okay
um and that's it so that is the plan
initially I have heard that there are
other projects in development as well as
this
so let's see what James Gunn has other
plans and but that is the initial
that's the plan so far so what do I
initially think of that
I don't like the Superman thing I think
Henry Cavill is Superman I think if
you're going to allow
things like
um The Flash and that character him Ezra
to continue to be the Flash and Aquaman
as well but apparently he James Gunn has
said that there's the potential for
these characters to stay in the DC that
these next couple of movies are coming
out are DC
um so that'll be Blue Beetle as well
which clever as a character I haven't
seen yet but Aquaman and the Flash and
they're going to be staying in the DC
but Henry Cavill isn't and we're going
to be having a new Superman so they are
going to be definitely picking and
choosing what is staying in Canon or
what is going to still be part of DC and
they're going to just ignore the rest so
again Batman has Ben Affleck they're
ignoring that they're going to forget
that happened
so they're going to forget that sort of
like everything in the snide of Earth
happened they're picking and choosing
they're cherry picking it seems to me
that they've got their hands tied a
little bit because they've got these
four big movies coming out which are
part of the old DC and now they've got
these new plans so they're going to
allow them to stay but what they're
saying is basically from today
but this is the DC
so Aquaman blah blah everything else has
happened from yesterday back
is
um
so we have a new DC
it's under James Gunn what do I think of
James Gunn very very briefly I thought
what do you do to run into the Galaxy
was brilliant the first one in
particular not so much the second one
and definitely not the Christmas special
we'll see what he does in the third one
um but what he did with Suicide Squad
was awful but then he pulled out
Peacemaker which was brilliant so James
Gunn is one of those
um creators that I think if he's given
the opportunity to do something and he
can do something brilliant but he does
need somebody just to Reign him in and
maybe that's that saffron guy maybe that
he's there just to sort of like look
you're the creative guy but I am gonna I
am gonna fence you in a little bit I am
gonna just pull you back when you go too
far I think really creative people need
that I always thought Tim Burton was one
of those that needs that when he goes
too far like you know the first Batman
movie was brilliant the second Batman
movie was too much Tim Burton and it
showed
um waikato is very similar to that the
first Ragnarok
brilliant movie it's the probably my
favorite Marvel film the love and
thunder is too much tiger and you know
he needed somebody to Reign him in so I
think James Gunn is a little bit like
that I think he needs somebody to Reign
him in so let's see what happens but hey
I think they're a really good and
interesting parts of that lost roster
um I think there are things I'm a bit
concerned about but as I say regardless
of how bad a story feels on the outset
it really depends on how that story is
told so
let's fingers crossed and see what they
can do with it if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe but the
Bell notification when he helps us out
and if you want to become a fully
fledged side tracker consider hitting
the join button also check the
description there are links to our nine
Chevrons website which is our Stargate
website there are links to our Facebook
group which I would love to come and
join
um Twitter and the merchandise page so
please go and check out those links as
always please stay safe and I'll see you
next time
thank you
[Music]